we are following breaking news from Hong
Kong where the government invoked
emergency powers overnight under a tough
and rarely used law from colonial days
now this includes a ban on mass during
public demonstrations remya any Ascencio
is in Hong Kong
ramie what does this mean now for the
protesters today's announcement sent off
a fresh wave of protests just like the
scene right behind me in Hong Kong
central business district just a few
hours ago chief executive Caroline
enacted the emergency regulations
ordinance it gives the government the
power to enact any law they want and
today they banned the use of mass at
public protests the move comes after a
March excavation in the violence that's
rocked Hong Kong since June and
culminating in the police shooting an 18
year old protester earlier this week
earlier today I asked Carrie Lam who's
appointed by Beijing whether her
decision was hers alone did you get
Beijing's approval to do this there was
absolutely no interaction discussion and
counters whatsoever with any central
People's Government officials on this
matter during my very brief stay in
Beijing this band is similar to bands in
several US states police are expected to
enact it starting midnight tonight
Anthony Ramey Inocencio in Hong Kong
thanks